hey this is presto Walker reminding you
to mind your decisions tunngle draws two
rectangles a b c d and a b EF whose
edges are integers in centimeters the
area of ABCD is 20 square centimeters
and a b EF is 10 square centimeters
which is the minimum possible perimeter
of rectangle c DF e in centimeters is it
twelve fourteen twenty two or twenty six
I think I tell from Turkey for
suggesting this problem it was intended
for students in the eighth grade who are
roughly 13 years of age this problem is
adapted from a practice book can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution so I admit this
problem stumped me and I'm first going
to present my wrong answer so let's go
over the problem step by step tone we'll
draw two rectangles so first I'll draw a
rectangle ABCD and then I'll draw a
rectangle a BEF the area of ABCD is 20
square centimeters and a BEF is 10
square centimeters so a label a B as X
this means CD is equal to X and EF is
also equal to X since ABCD has an area
of 20 square centimeters BC will be
equal to 20 over X and its opposite side
will also be 20 over X since a BEF has
an area of 10 that means these sides
will be 10 over X what is the minimum
possible perimeter of rectangle CD Fe so
we want the perimeter of this entire
rectangle so the perimeter will be the
sum of all the lengths this simplifies
to be 2x plus 60 over X now recalling
that all of the edges of each rectangle
are integers we know that 10 over X is
an integer so we need to check for
values of X which are factors of 10 and
this will be 1 2 5 and 10 and we get the
following possible perimeters the
minimum perimeter will be 22 and that's
what I thought the answer was but I was
wrong
so where did I go wrong let's present
the correct answer so I actually was
wrong in the very first step when I drew
this diagram I thought this was the only
way you could draw these two rectangles
but for this problem you don't need to
think outside the box you actually need
to think inside the box this is how the
diagram should be drawn to get the
minimum possible perimeter of CD Fe so
now we essentially need to follow the
same steps but we end up with a
different result for the minimum
perimeter so here we have the two
rectangles
now we'll label this side as X the area
of ABCD is 20 square centimeters which
means BC will be equal to 20 over X now
since a vef has the area of 10 that
means this side will be 10 over X
consequently we know that this side EC
has to be 10 over X and its opposite
side will also be 10 over X now let's
calculate the perimeter of CD Fe we
calculate the sum of these links this
will simplify to be 2x plus 20 over X we
again look for factors of 10 so we check
the factors 1 2 5 and 10 and here we get
the minimum perimeter of 14 and that's
the correct answer so going back to the
problem the correct answer is B 14
centimeters it was a pretty tricky
problem and it certainly stumped me but
I really enjoyed it because it reminded
me that sometimes you don't need to
think outside the box but you need to
think inside the box
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on YouTube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world
they have over a hundred million
and the channel has over 1 million
subscribers thanks for watching and
thanks for your support
[Music]